et on commence donc par les états unis
toujours aussi déterminés à faire
traduire julian assange devant la
justice américaine
en janvier dernier le jugement la juge
britannique avait refusé de l'extrader
en raison des risques qui pesait sur sa
vie washington a fait appel de la
décision
voyez la correspondance sur place de
notre journaliste thomas bonnet
lors du refus par une juge britannique
d'extrader julian assange en janvier
dernier les autorités judiciaires
américaines s'était dit extrêmement déçu
après avoir fait appel de cette décision
le département de justice américain
attend donc l'issue de ces audiences
avec la même volonté celle de juger le
journaliste australien aux états unis où
il encourt une peine allant jusqu'à 175
ans d'emprisonnement il n'y a donc aucun
fléchissement du côté de washington et
l'élection de joe biden n'a rien changé
sur le dossier de julian assange et du
côté des défenseurs des libertés en
revanche le combat continue surtout
après les révélations saisissantes
publiée il ya un mois par le site yahoo
news on y découvrait via des sources
cité de manière anonyme que des plans
avait été imaginé en 2017 au sein de la
cia pour une opération à londres selon
ces sources des discussions ont été
menées pour fomenter des projets
d'enlèvements voire même d'assassinât de
john assange des plans dont rien
n'indique qu'ils ont finalement été
validés par la maison blanche mais qui
provoque une vive inquiétude à des ong
dont human rights watch ou encore
amnesty international ont adressé une
lettre au procureur général des états
unis nous vous exhortons
respectueusement à abandonner la paix
long cours de la décision du juge barre
et soeurs et à rejeter l'acte
d'accusation
le récit de yahoo news ne fait
qu'accroître nos inquiétudes quant aux
motivations derrière ces poursuites et
aux dangereux précédent qui est en train
d'être créée
de son côté mike pompéo qui a été
successivement directeur de la cia puis
secrétaire d'état sous la présidence de
donald trump exige au contraire que les
sources qui sont cités dans cet article
de yahoo soient poursuivis pour avoir
bafoué la confidentialité et la
classification des informations en
question en tout cas on peut dire que
c'est dans un silence assourdissant des
médias mainstream amélie bien que se
joue le sort de julian assange l'afer
est très peu couvertes dans les
principaux médias du pays qu'ils ont
pourtant d'habitude si prompt à tendre
leurs micros au lanceur d'alert